SEAN.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
A LOT OF SPECULATION OUT
THERE.
THANKS, ED HENRY.
HE IS DETECTED IN
HE IS CETECTED IN
HE IS CONECTED IN
HE IS CONNETED IN
HE IS CONNECTD IN
HE IS CONNECTEDIN
HE IS CONNECTED IN D.C.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR NEWT
GINGRICH.
MR. SPEAKER, I CAN'T GET
OVER TWO VERY IMPORTANT
THINGS HERE.
THAT IS COMEY AND STRZOK'S
EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION AND THEN A
FISA MEMO THAT THEY KNOW
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
THAT'S UNVERIFIED BY ANYBODY
THAT IS PRESENTED TO A FISA
COURT AND THEN THEY DON'T
TELL THE FISA COURT THAT
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
THE RUSSIA LIES.
THIS IS SCARY -- THIS IS
ABOUT IMPACTING THE
ELECTIONS AND THE ABSOLUTE
INTEGRITY OF ELECTIONS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> LOOK, I THINK WE ARE IN
GEORGE ORWELL TERRITORY.
THIS IS WHY HE WROTE IN
1984.
HE WAS TERRIFIED AS HE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT THE POWER
OF A STATE TO BEGIN TO
CHANGE HISTORY AND TO FORCE
PEOPLE TO LEARN A FAKE
HISTORY.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE -- I
MEAN, YOU AND I TALKED OF
THIS.
EVERY DAY SOMETHING NEW
UNRAVELS.
SOMETHING FALLS OUT WHO
WOULD HAVE DREAMED OF SUSAN
RICE WRITING A MEMO TO
HERSELF THE WAY SHE DID 15
DAYS AFTER A MEETING AND THE
MEMO SURE SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A
WHITE WASH MEMO.
IT'S A LET ME WRITE THIS
DOWN SO IF ANYBODY EVER ASKS
IT WILL LOOK CORRECT.
WHO WOULD HAVE IMAGINED AS
WE ARE LEARNING MORE AND
MORE ABOUT THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE CIA WHO
CERTAINLY SOUNDS THE MORE WE
LEARN ABOUT IT, LIKE HE IS
THE WORST POSSIBLE PERSON TO
HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH THE
CIA DURING THAT PERIOD.
I MEAN, AND EVERY TIME WE
TURN AROUND, THERE IS SOME
NEW AND I THINK VERY
SOBERING REVELATION THAT
DOESN'T FIT THE WORLD YOU
AND I THOUGHT WE LIVED IN.
>> Sean: WHY WOULD I READ
SUSAN RICE'S MEMO, DO I READ
INTO THAT UH-OH THERE MIGHT
BE SOMETHING ELSE AND THAT'S
WHY THE CIA WAS DONE 15 DAYS
LATER.
THEN I SEE THE INVOLVEMENT
OF BRENNAN AND CLAPPER.
THEN I LOOKED AT WHAT I JUST
MENTIONED ABOUT COMEY
EXONERATING.
THIS WHOLE THING WAS RIGID.
JAMES CALLSTRUM IS RIGHT.
AND THEN THE FISA MEMO.
>> I CONTINUE TO TELL PEOPLE
I THINK THE MOST FASCINATING
SINGLE THING IS STRZOK'S
TEXT MESSAGE TO HIS
GIRLFRIEND OR VISA VERSA
THAT THEY HAVE TO PREPARE
THIS MEETING FOR COMEY
BECAUSE COMEY IS GOING TO
BRIEF OBAMA AND THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO KNOW
EVERYTHING.
NOW, I NEVER HEARD COMEY SAY
HE HAD BRIEFED THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES STRIKES
ME PRETTY EASY TO SAY TO THE
CONGRESS HAVE YOU GOT TO
BRING COMEY BACK IN UNDER
OATH.
HOW OFTEN DID YOU BRIEF THE
PRESIDENT?
WHAT DID YOU BRIEF HIM
ABOUT?
WHAT WAS HE CONCERNED ABOUT?
I MEAN, WE'RE REALLY RIGHT
AT THE EDGE OF SENATOR
HOWARD BAKER SAYING, YOU
KNOW, THE QUESTION IS WHAT
DID THE PRESIDENT KNOW AND
WHEN DID HE LEARN IT?
>> Sean: IT REALLY HAS TAKEN
A TURN IN THAT DIRECTION.
>> DOWN TO LORETTA LYNCH.
THE PRESIDENT TO LORETTA
LYNCH WHO IS MEETING WITH
BILL CLINTON THE WEEK THAT
HIS WIFE WAS GOING TO BE
INTERVIEWED, INTERVIEW BEING
SORT OF A PHONY TERM BY
COMEY WHO HAS ALREADY BEEN
WRITING HER EXONERATION FOR
TWO MONTHS BEFORE THE
INTERVIEW.
I MEAN, YOU COULDN'T MAKE
THIS UP AS A SERIOUS NOVEL
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
PIECES HERE THAT ARE ILLEGAL
THAT YOU COULDN'T MAGAZINIER
PEOPLE DOING.
THIS.
>> Sean: EVERY NIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM I'M ADDING NEW
INFORMATION AND STILL,
BECAUSE THE STORY IS -- IT'S
GETTING SO BIG, IMPACTING SO
MANY PEOPLE, YOU KIND OF
HAVE TO BUILD THE BRIDGE
EVERY NIGHT SO EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE NEW
INFORMATION IS.
BUT I WANT TO STAY FOCUSED
ON THIS FISA FOR A SECOND.
IT WAS UNVERIFIED BY FUSION
GPS.
UNVERIFIED BY THE FBI.
THEY KNEW HILLARY BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR IT, AND THEY DIDN'T
TELL THE FISA JUDGE.
AND IT WASN'T DONE JUST
ONCE.
THEY ATTEMPTED IT IN JULY.
THEY DIDN'T GET IT.
THEN THEY DID IT IN OCTOBER
AND THEY GOT IT THEN THEY
RENEWED IT THREE TIMES.
AND THE BULK OF INFORMATION
THAT WAS PRESENTED WAS THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER THAT THEY NEVER
INFORMED THE JUDGE ABOUT.
I MEAN, IF I'M THAT FISA
JUDGE, I'M CALLING THOSE
PEOPLE BACK IN YESTERDAY.
>> WELL, LOOK, AT THIS POINT
YOU ALSO HAVE TO SAY WHEN IS
THE CONGRESS -- EXCUSE ME.
WHEN IS THE CONGRESS GOING
TO CALL IN THE FISA JUDGE?
WHAT WAS THE FISA JUDGE
THINKING?
WHY DID HE DO IT?
EXCUSE ME.
WHY DIDN'T HE ASK THESE
QUESTIONS?
I MEAN, IT'S NOT IMPLAUSIBLE
TO SAY TO THE FBI, GOSH,
WHERE DID YOU GET THIS
DOSSIER FROM?
HOW WAS IT PRODUCED?
HAVE YOU VALIDATED IT?
APPARENTLY THE FBI VALIDATED
NOTHING.
THEY TOOK THIS DOCUMENT.
THEY WALKED IN AND THEY GAVE
IT TO THEM WITHOUT ANY
VALIDATION.
>> Sean: YEAH.
UNBELIEVABLE.
I AGREE WITH YOU,
MR. SPEAKER.
I DO BELIEVE -- JUST LAST
QUESTION.
HISTORICALLY.
I KEEP SAYING IT IS SO MUCH
BIGGER THAN WATERGATE
BECAUSE OF THE USE, THE
HIGHEST LEVELS, THE HIGHEST
ECHELONS IN INTELLIGENCE,
THE FBI, THE DOJ.
AND THE ABSOLUTE ABUSE OF
POWER THE INTELLIGENCE
WEAPONRY WE HAVE AND ALSO
THE DECEPTION TO THE FISA
JUDGE.
>> LOOK, I BELIEVE THIS IS
THE CLEAREST EXAMPLE WE HAVE
HAD OF, EXCUSE ME, THE
DANGER OF A DEEP STATE.
HERE YOU HAVE BUREAUCRATS
OUT OF CONTROL WITH THE
POWER OF THE GOVERNMENT,
THREATENING, I THINK TO
UNDERMINE THE ENTIRE
PROCESS, INCLUDING BLOCKING,
EXCUSE ME, BLOCKING TRUMP
FROM BEING PRESIDENT AND
PROTECTING HILLARY AND IT'S
ONLY AN ACCIDENT.
I MEAN, LET'S NOT KID
OURSELVES.
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
IN WASHINGTON, PENNSYLVANIA
CHANGED HILLS I HAVE WHERE
WE WOULD HAVE LEARNED
NOTHING ABOUT THIS.